es lunes y es momento de hablar de
economía y por ello saludo y con mucho
gusto a daniela hablando la especialista
económica daniela empezamos hablando de
la dueña de 'tik tok' que ya escogió a
la firma que manejará sus operaciones en
eeuu
así es alan muy buenas noches se trata
de oracle que venció a microsoft en la
puja por las operaciones estadounidenses
de la aplicación china esto como parte
de la amenaza de estados unidos de que
bloquearía la aplicación si a mediados
de septiembre su dueño byte de ans no
había vendido a sus operaciones en el
país lo que no está muy claro al danés
sin embargo si oracle será más bien una
especie de operador o de proveedor así
que habrá que esperar las autorizaciones
de ambos gobiernos la casa blanca podría
emitir la esta misma semana pero la
dificultad vendría por el lado de china
escuchemos esto ha expuesto
completamente las verdaderas intenciones
de ciertos políticos estadounidenses de
robo disfrazado y bajo coacción así como
su desagradable rostro de acoso
económico china se opone firmemente a
esto
nos vamos a brasil danger ahí es que el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro veto una
millonaria condonación de deudas a las
iglesias recibir el congreso de ese país
aprobó recientemente la condonación de
deudas por alrededor de 190 millones de
dólares a las iglesias pero hoy el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro veto esta
norma y lo hizo a regañadientes lo
curioso lo es que el presidente dijo que
si él fuera diputado de rock haría esa
decisión en su cuenta de 'twitter'
sugirió que según la ley de directrices
presupuestarias y de responsabilidad
fiscal se ve obligado a vetar la
disposición que eximía a las iglesias de
un aporte sobre su utilidad neta todo
para evitar un proceso de juicio
político casi seguro otra curiosidad es
que entre los deudores están las
iglesias evangelistas que son parte de
la base política del líder de
ultraderecha bolsonaro dijo que los
impuestos a las iglesias son absurdos y
se comprometió a buscar por otro camino
la inmunidad tributaria de estos
despachos religiosos buenos con una
noticia que involucra a las 20 mayores
economías del mundo y es que el producto
interno bruto de estas naciones
y una caída histórica fue una caída
conjunta estamos hablando del segundo
trimestre sin precedentes del 69 por
ciento frente al primer trimestre de
este año todo a causa de la pandemia las
caídas están encabezadas por india con
más del 25 2% el reino unido con poco
más del 20 por ciento y gméxico entre
tanto los que tuvieron un desempeño
menos peor fueron rusia corea del sur
cuya actividad se contrajo en 3,2 por
ciento en el segundo trimestre y el caso
asombroso es el de china cuya economía
en lugar de caer está creciendo y a muy
buen ritmo en el segundo trimestre
escaló 11,5 por ciento a la valla donde
surgió precisamente la pandemia también
la un opositor de los gobiernos de cuba
y venezuela quedó al frente del banco
interamericano de desarrollo si la
controversial elección del presidente
del bid que es el principal prestamista
de la región no causa ninguna sorpresa
en realidad el elegido fue postulado por
eeuu
mauricio claver carone quien era el
único candidato y fue asesor prince
de donald trump para la región el nació
en cuba pero es ciudadano estadounidense
el primero no la tiene en dirigir la
entidad en 61 años de historia esto hizo
que muchos países de latinoamérica y
hasta la unión europea criticaron su
elección y se volviera toda una batalla
geopolítica a pesar de que el candidato
de trump logró 30 de los 48 votos 16
países se abstuvieron de votar entre
ellos argentina méxico chile y perú
quienes habían pedido retrasar la
votación bonos ahora con los indicadores
económicos del día las tecnológicas de
repuntando de nuevo hicieron que wall
street cerrará en positivo todos los
índices ganaron más del 1 por ciento en
las plazas europeas hubo resultados
mixtos sobre todo por los débiles datos
económicos en los diferentes países y en
américa latina' la tercera jornada
consecutiva de caídas pronunciadas en la
bolsa de comercio de buenos aires a las
primeras amos con la cifra del día le va
a gustar a la cndh son los 92 millones
de euros que invirtió una empresa suiza
en la casa del chocolate esto es un
museo en el que se exhibe la fuente
grande del mundo de nueve metros de
altura ustedes ven en pantalla esta
delicia estelar acaba de abrir sus
puertas al público aprovechando el día
internacional del chocolate que se
celebró el domingo se le celebró al año
si se comiendo muchos por cierto y justo
ahorita para abrir apetito vamos ya a
cabo tu crónica es momento ideal sí
señor gracias daniela por este recorrido
económico y ustedes por su compañía ya
lo sabe como a chocolate y vea france24
[Música]